in your last drawer you told the story
because if you always imagine that your
life is just glamour glamour glamour
sometimes work does get in the way you
luck you lost you lost or told the story
about Frank Sinatra Oh Frank
yes oh I don't know the people could say
Frank jealous I just remember I went to
Hollywood when I was 20 at the end of
the Golden Age when you know the guilt
was beginning to turn so I met everybody
I met Humphrey Bogart Lana Turner and
Hedy Lamarr and Frank Sinatra and you
know it was amazing so about ten years
later eight years later I'm doing this
movie called the road to Hong Kong with
two more legends Bing Crosby and Bob
Hope and we had two people who coming on
three people who are coming on the Rat
Pack it was Sammy Davis jr. Dean Martin
and Frank Sinatra and we had a scene
together it was the most ridiculous film
we were I was sent off into space Hong
Kong but it ended up the road to space
I'm in Sunday in a sort of space up that
and two spacemen are there either side
of me one is Dean Martin the other one
is Frank Sinatra and they both are
fighting over me and trying to kiss me
and it was you know really great till I
mean you know I was still pretty
starstruck then and so I'm living at
home with my mother and father and and
the next day in morning the phone rings
and mummy comes in and she says it's
Frank Sinatra on the phone for you I
said Frank Sinatra hey so I said oh um
hi and he said hi it's Frank um he said
um how would you like to have dinner
with me and I said oh well that would be
very nice yes he said uh he said
tomorrow I said yeah he said I'll send
my plane for you I said you're playing
where are you
he said Hamburg in Hamburg I said why
can't possibly go to Hamburg I mean I've
got an early call tomorrow he said um
I'll change your call
I said will you come to that I I mean
I'm a serious actress I you can't change
Michael just because you want to have
that hung up and that was it he never
asked me again but I hear he asked Linda
Evans and she went
zel right right is it he's got like a
master Baker's wrist Billy's hand
they're teaching he's not teaching me a
shot there seems to me you're like a
pregnant woman and to me looking Lourdes